and finally new rule Americans need to
find a better way to say I disagree with
your position then I'm going to kill you
it's one of the few things the left and
the right have in common now Adam Schiff
and Chuck Schumer received death threats
for impeaching Trump and Susan Collins
got death threats for not impeaching him
a guy named Salvatore lipeh was arrested
last week for calling shifts office and
saying I dare you to come to New York as
I will put a bullet in your [ __ ]
forehead and then he went back to the
bar and started screaming how come women
don't like nice guys
last week some Bernie bros got very
angry at the culinary union in Nevada
for preferring their own current health
care plan to Bernie's Medicare for all
and as we know the price for advocating
for an alternative health care plan is
death except these are people on your
own team fellow workers fellow Democrats
with a slightly different idea who you
want to kill this is what was so
frightening to Kurama Brown one of the
stars on queer eye who got death threats
after saying he planned to be nice to
Republican Shawn Spencer unde ancing
with the Stars mr. Brown said the minute
that my son started getting death
threats was the worst moment for me
because a lot of it wasn't coming from
the other side it was coming from my own
side his own side death threats from
liberals to children over this
why don't they just make an app for
death threats you could call it ender
look I'm not saying there's no place for
blind blood loss like in the Bible or
when they run out of the chicken
sandwich of Popeyes but everything a
singer who wore her support for Trump
proudly to the Grammys got death threats
Gayle King got death threats for asking
a too soon question about Kobe Bryant
Ilan Omar gets death threats for being
an immigrant and death threats went out
to a woman who wrote a pro immigrant
book because she wasn't actually an
immigrant the Ukraine whistleblower got
death threats and nobody even knew who
it was they just sent open letters to
whom it may concern I'm going to kill
him
this is what happens when you let cancel
culture spin out of control it's the
same attitude just taking a little
further we take your livelihood let's
just go ahead and take your life because
all the geniuses in this country are so
1 million percent sure they're right
about everything that's always just my
way or the dye way you know Trump may
want to be a dictator but he is hardly
alone a lot of people in this country
love to say off with their head don't
like that thing you purchased threatened
to burn down the factory don't agree
with someone who won the Oscar tell them
I'm gonna find where they live and slit
their throat don't like to call the ref
made at your kids soccer game send them
a picture of you brandishing an axe
when did Americans become the fatwa
people
every minor dispute has to go from zero
to Mel Gibson in three seconds did you
know that the new pop sensation Billy
Eilish spent her big night at the
Grammys apologizing for winning yeah
because her overriding emotion wasn't
pride it was fear that super fans of
rival pop stars would attack her oh if
only we had this kind of passion for
something that mattered in this country
Billy Eilish kept winning all night and
she kept saying things like no please
don't let it be me and all the other
artists in this category I know your
fans are gonna talk [ __ ] about me for
years because of this imagine being 18
winning five Grammys and all you could
think of is oh [ __ ] they know where I
live you know things are out of control
when even potheads are issuing death
threats yeah reporter Alex Berenson
recently cited a link between weave
legalization and a rise in violent crime
and pro cannabis activists wanted his
head on a pike let me tell you if you're
a stoner and you want to kill someone
you might consider switching from sativa
to indica
you